in today's video we'll be going through
the story of mikasa ackerman from attack
on titan
let's start with the backstory
mikasa was born to an asian mother and
her father was a member of the ackermann
clan she lived peacefully with her
parents in the farmlands of walmaria
helping them since a young age mikasa
underwent a painful scarring ritual from
her mother who cut into her skin the
mark of their family being the last of
their race made her mother and mikasa
high value targets to robbers when she
was only nine years old a group of
traffickers killed her parents and
attempted to kidnap her for the purpose
of selling her in the human trading
market of the capitals underground
frightened and shocked mikasa was
rescued by aaron yeager the son of her
family's doctor he tricked and killed
two of the kidnappers but he was
overwhelmed by the third trafficker and
on the verge of being strangled aaron
desperately urged mikasa to fight to win
who came to realize that the world can
be callous and merciless before
dispatching the robber from behind who
was trying to kill him when grisha
jaeger arrived with members of the
military police brigade mikasa was given
the scarf by aaron and accepted into his
family this event awakened the fighting
instincts and perfect self-control that
runs in the ackermann clan mikasa then
went to live with aaron's family until
the fall of walmaria migusa appears for
the first time in year 845 somewhere
inside wall maria she is seen waking
aaron up telling him that they need to
return to home she is surprised to see
tears in his eyes and asks why he was
crying on the way home they met hannah's
mikasa watches as aaron complains about
the soldiers slacking off while on duty
later both aaron and mikasa watched the
return of the survey corps forces
witnessing yet another failure of their
expedition after returning home mikasa
tells on aaron revealing to his parents
his desire to join the survey corps
annoyed aaron leaves with mikasa
following him they save armin who is
being beaten by local bullies and
together discuss their desire to go
outside the walls at that moment the
three kids witnessed the sudden
appearance of an extremely tall titan
peering over the top of walmaria the
three are stunned to see one that large
only coming back to their senses when
the titan breaches the wall's gate
mikasa and aaron run back to their home
to find it crushed and carla trapped
under the debris in spite of their
attempts mikasa and aaron are unable to
free her hanus rescues them as a titan
devours aaron's mother mikasa and aaron
are placed on a ship just as the armored
titan breaks through the inner gate
letting the titans inside walmaria she
witnesses aaron's vow to kill all the
titans as they are transported to safety
after the events of walmare's
destruction the government's desperate
attempt to reclaim the lands using the
refugees leads to nothing but more
casualties this prompts mikasa aaron and
armin to enroll with the army and become
members of the 104th training corps
during their training mikasa helps aaron
as much as she can as he initially fails
to grasp the basics of the vertical
maneuvering equipment mikasa quickly
proving her skills and is praised as one
of the best trainees in military history
at one point mikasa asks annie leonhardt
a fellow trainee with exceptional skill
to teach her a self-defense technique
that she was teaching aaron which
eventually calls for a bet with the
104th training court to see who is the
stronger fighter at the 104th training
corps graduation she is ranked first in
class before having the chance to fully
apply in the survey core so she can keep
aaron safe the colossus titan breaches
wall rose the same way it did with moab
maria much to her dismay mikasa is
assigned to the rear guard to help fend
off the titans while the civilians
escape into the safety of wall sheena
before fulfilling her duty she makes
aaron promise her not to do anything
reckless later on as an abnormal titan
approaches the escaping civilians who
are blocked at the gate mikasa kills it
saving everyone she then witnesses why
the civilians are taking too long to
escape an overloaded cargo cart is
blocking the way mikasa asks the
businessman to move the card so that the
people could escape but when he refuses
she has to resort threatening him after
knocking his guards unconscious which
scares the man enough to relent and move
his goods seeing a mother and daughter
show their gratitude for saving them
mikasa flashes back to the time she lost
her own parents and realizes that erin
is the only family she has left with the
evacuation of cross district citizens
complete she heads to the front guard in
order to aid her comrades mikasa finds
that because the supply team has
barricaded itself inside the military
headquarters the surviving trainees no
longer have enough gas to retreat
noticing that aaron is not present
mikasa confronts armin and learns that
aaron was devoured by a titan despite
his clear regret mikasa calmly comforts
armon and explains that they must not
get emotional in their present
predicament mikasa rallies the remaining
trainees and leads them in a last-ditch
effort to reach the headquarters because
of her grief over aaron's death mikasa
rushes ahead of her comrades and quickly
expends oliver gas stranding herself in
the middle of trust as two titans close
in on her she contemplates giving up but
is motivated to keep fighting by
memories of aaron when mikasa stands up
to kill the titan in front of her
another titan comes running from behind
and saves her this titan which ignores
mikasa gives armin enough time to rescue
mikasa and they both continue heading to
the supply hq as they watch the attack
titan continue killing other titans they
hatch a plan to lure to the hq and
relieve the siege there with its help
the trainees managed to successfully
refill their gas tanks and have clear
access to the wall however as they watch
the attack titan dispose of the last
titan surrounding them aaron appears out
of the nape of his neck overcome with
relief that aaron is alive mikasa
quickly rescues and embraces him
everyone leaving for the wall however
gene along with annie reiner and bertolt
are ordered to hand aaron over to
superior officers under the command of
kits wildman and to treat the incident
as something confidential their refusal
to do so causes mikasa and her friends
to be accused of treason and find
themselves surrounded by the captain's
men who are prompt to execute them
mikasa attempts to defend aaron by
drawing her blades and threatening to
kill anyone who would try to harm aaron
but witnessing aaron's titan from
fighting in tross district walman does
not hesitate and orders a cannon to fire
at them in spite of the latter's claim
that he is a human aaron uses his power
to block the cannonball and tries to
think of a plan of escape he proposes
that they either try to flee over the
walls and escape into the titan
territory or have armin attempt to
persuade the soldiers to spare them
leaving him to choose armin tries his
best to convince the soldiers that
aaron's titan abilities could help save
humanity but realizes the commander is
far too scared to think rationally
before the order can be given to fire
upon them once more they are saved when
commander dot pixes head administrator
of the southern region intervenes they
are sent on a mission to plug the breach
in the wall with a rock that only aaron
in titan form can lift as the mission
commences and aaron goes into titan form
he loses control and attacks mikasa
before eventually knocking himself out
thanks to armin's intervention aaron
eventually regains his senses and
successfully places the rock down albeit
with many casualties at that moment they
are saved by levi as he kills the titans
approaching them after the battle of
trust district is over aaron is brought
before a military tribunal to decide his
future despite mikasa's best efforts to
defend him she's forced to testify
against aaron as his reckless actions
have frightened many people in the
courtroom she is also forced to watch
helplessly as aaron is assaulted and
humiliated by levi sometime later mikasa
and everyone else have their vertical
maneuvering equipment inspected in order
to find out the culprit who killed the
two captured titans later on commander
irwin smith comes to recruit new members
for the survey corps which is scheduling
an expedition within a few months many
leave except for mikasa reiner armin
sasha krista ymir connie jean bertolt
and a few others mikasa is then seen to
be a part of the 57th expedition shortly
after leaving for walmaria the female
titan appears and defeats numerous
survey corps members the formation
eventually reaches the titan forest with
mikasa being stationed at its outskirts
making sure that no titans enter the
forest as the corps is preparing to
return to wall roads mikasa hears the
roar of aaron's titan and abandons her
post to go and help him mikasa finds
aaron just in time to see the female
titan defeat and devour him after
overcoming her initial shock mikasa
begins an enraged assault on the female
titan cutting it up to try to rescue
aaron her attacks proved to be
ineffectual against the titan until she
is joined by levi mikasa insists that
aaron is still alive and levi agrees to
help rescue him with levi coordinating
their attacks they quickly overwhelm the
titan but mikasa becomes reckless and
attempts to kill the titan against
levi's orders levi is wounded saving her
from the titan but manages to cut open
his jaw in the process mikasa retrieves
aaron from the titan's mouth and the
group retreats following the survey
corps's failure army manages to convince
annie to help them out until they can
gather evidence to prove to the king
that the walls need to be protected
better she prepares for battle when she
gets fed up with annie's games she takes
off her disguise and draws out her sword
to fighter promising to cut up the
female titan one more time when aaron is
unable to initially transform and shows
some hesitancy in fighting annie mikasa
berates him and decides to go with armin
to distract annie until aaron is able to
transform eventually aaron arrives and
starts to fight annie but it's made
apparent that he is not powerful enough
to defeat annie by himself being the
strongest and most powerful soldier
herself she decides to take the fight to
her despite being ordered to pull away
by hanji zoe mikasa manages to make it
to annie as she attempted to climb over
wall sheena to escape to the flatlands
aaron throws mikasa upwards so she can
catch up with the female titan and cut
off all her fingers she then proceeds to
push annie off to fall to the ground and
he is therefore captured but encases
herself in a crystal to avoid
interrogation however it was far from
over as mikasa has just taken notice of
a titan inside the wall as both the
survey court and military police take an
uncased annie underground to detain her
mikasa realizes the titan hiding in
waushina is alive but is too weak to
move due to a lack of sunlight mikasa
remains at aaron's bedside as armin and
john head down to a meeting involving
irwin and the military police following
the supposed breach of wall rose mikasa
aaron and other members of the survey
court come to rescue reiner and the
others from the other titans she is
among the others who learn of krista's
real name being historia after they
reach the top of wall rose mikasa is
outraged when she overhears reiner
confessing that he and bertolt were the
titans responsible for the attack on wal
maria and wanted aaron to join them she
takes them by surprise attacking them
with her swords and tells aaron to run
however she fails to kill them as reiner
stops her from doing so transforming
afterward and attempting to kidnap aaron
while aaron transforms and engages in
battle with reiner mikasa faces her own
troubles and regrets for not cutting off
both his and bertolt's heads when she
had the chance during the fight with
reiner she sees aaron in trouble and
tries to fight him off however due to
the thickness of the armor mikasa has a
hard time slicing the nape of reiner's
neck eventually armin sees a weak link
in reiner's line of defense in which his
armor is breaking and gives mikasa extra
blades to replace her own taking
advantage of the information she cuts
him at the back of the kneecaps however
berthold manages to save reiner thanks
to his abilities of the colossus titan
knocking out most of the soldiers in the
process later mikasa along with hanji
and others from the survey court are
injured from the heat blast from
berthold's titan form while armin helps
them recover he gives mika said the news
that she was dreading to hear aaron
along with yamir was kidnapped by both
reiner and bertolt taking the scarf that
he gave her mikasa covers her face with
it and asks why erin always runs off on
them like that she feels that she has
failed in keeping her promise to aaron's
mother to always protect him in weeps as
armin tries to console her hannes
arrives to give out rations to the
legion it was him who reminds her that
despite him running off the way he does
and often losing fights he never gives
up on them even though the odds are
stacked against him and he is unwilling
to admit it hannes always knew that
aaron relied on both mikasa and armin
when he needed them his words and his
assistance reinvigorated them and are
more determined to rescue aaron she
joins the joint military operation to
rescue aaron and heads to the forest of
giant trees where they hope to find
reiner bertolt and their captives once
they arrive she joins hannes and a
number of her fellow soldiers in
searching the inside of the force where
they encounter yamir in her titan form
yamir kidnaps historia and flees while
mikasa and the others chase after her at
the forest's edge rhino transforms into
the armored titan mimir jumps on his
back and berthold carrying an
unconscious aaron rides on his shoulder
the soldiers followed the group on
horseback and tried to free aaron from
berthold but yamir interferes with their
attempts realizing that armor was
protecting reiner's joints this whole
time she instead targets yamir and
slashes into her face
historia jumps in the way saying that
ymir does not have a choice but to help
reiner amber told fearing that yamir
will be killed historia convinces her to
back down leaving the rest of the 104th
free to try talking berthold into
letting aaron go though mikasa is
considerably less forgiving than the
others jean and connie try to speak to
bertolt and coax him into surrendering
but mikasa coldly states that their
reasons do not matter she has
momentarily stayed by bertolt's
apologies for what he and reiner have
done but when she requests again that
aaron be returned bertold refuses before
the group can argue further hannah
shouts a warning to them that a huge
group of titans is being led straight
towards them by irwin smith mikasa
retreats but it's not long before irwin
orders them to attack one more time
claiming this to be the key moment for
humanity's survival mikasa makes a dash
to reach aaron and launches herself at
bertholdt but she misses and sees aaron
watching her in panic her trajectory
carries her strain into another titan
that grabs her hard enough to crush her
ribs jean who had been riding just
behind her attacks the titan burying his
blade in its eye and allowing mikasa to
get free with armin's help irwin is able
to cut aaron free from bertolt and
mikasa catches him in the air the two of
them flee on horseback but are knocked
to the ground when reiner begins
throwing titans at the retreating
soldiers as they'd look up they see the
smiling titan which ate aaron's mother
approaching them mikasa is unable to
defend aaron due to her injury but
hannes buys them time in an attempt to
avenge carla aaron shouts for mikasa to
free his arms so he can help fight but
when he tries biting himself to
transform nothing happens as hanus is
killed and the battle turns against the
soldiers around them aaron falls into
despair feeling that he has never had
the power to do anything mikasa asks him
to listen to her he showed her how to
live with purpose and he wrapped his
scarf around her and for that she is
grateful she smiles with tears in her
eyes and aaron vows to wrap that scarf
around her as many times as she wants he
punches the smiling titan triggering
something that causes all the other
mindless titans to attack it in the
resulting confusion he carries mikasa
away on his back and also sends the
titans after reiner and bertolt they
escape with the rest of the surviving
soldiers and return to toss district
mikasa and the rest of the joint
military operation participants arrive
back at wall rose a short time later
she's recovered enough that she feels
well enough to cut firewood while she
hides out in a remote cabin along with
jean connie sasha army historia and
aaron the new members of levi's special
operations squad she is present when
levi holds a meeting at the cabin with
his squad and hanjis they discuss
recapturing walmaria assuming that aaron
can harden his titan form to plug the
hole there are complications however
with the death of minister nick at the
hands of the interior military police
mikasa and the rest of levi's squad
observe hanji's experiments with aaron
they don't go smoothly though and mikasa
has to resort to using her blades to cut
aaron out of his titan after his third
attempt results in aaron only partially
transforming and becoming unresponsive
levi gripes over their lackluster
results since aaron cannot harden
himself and without that ability they
cannot reclaim wall maria mikasa defends
aaron's efforts but levi assures her he
does not blame aaron he just needs to
vent at night they receive orders from
irwin and levi asks those members of his
squad dumb enough to trust the commander
to come with him they managed to escape
before intruders reach their cabin and
hurry to their rendezvous point in tross
district there a carriage comes crashing
through and seemingly kidnaps aaron and
historia however the kidnapped victims
are actually jean and armin in disguise
mikasa joins levi and the rest of their
squad in tracking the robbers to their
hideout they attack the kidnappers
before jean and armin's disguise can be
discovered while mikasa herself is
tackling the ringleader who turns out to
be demo reeves the merchant boss who was
blocking the gate with his cargo that
they trust was invaded levi takes him
for a talk on top of wall rose after
hearing his story about being coerced by
the interior military police levi agrees
to hand over aaron and historia to
mikasa's consternation however levi has
multiple conditions that will require
the full cooperation of the reeves
company demo agrees and baits jail
sannes and ralph of the interior first
squad into a trap so they can be
captured by the survey corps mikasa and
the rest of levi's squad listen to jail
sannes's screams as he is tortured in
the basement of their current hideout
she does not comment as the rest of the
squad laments or endorse the actions
they have taken up until this point
armin says they are not good people
anymore as planned levi's squad begins
trailing the hearse carrying the two
coffins that contain aaron and historia
they hear gunshots revealing that levi
has been discovered and shortly after
they see him swing into view his
pursuers are outfitted with specialized
vertical maneuvering equipment designed
to allow the firing of guns levi lands
in the wagon and orders his squad to
stop following the hearse because it's a
trap when marlo freidenberg and hitch
drace come into the force to look for
survey corps soldiers mikasa and levi
ambush them while arma distracts them as
bait mikasa and armin take their
uniforms and put them on with the
intention of infiltrating the military
police to find out where aaron and
historia have been taken however marlo
and hitch do not take their capture
quietly hitch berates levi and marlow
offers to help their cause jean asks if
he can handle them and levi allows him
to secretly test their intentions when
they pass the squad uses their help to
launch an attack on an interior military
police compound after crippling most of
the people inside levi and his squad
escape with a hostage but they do not
find aaron in historia levi brutally
interrogates him about their location
until the name kenny ackerman comes out
mikasa is surprised upon hearing this
last name and levi reacts as well before
they can question their hostage further
they hear people approaching on foot the
newcomers turn out to be hanji marlow
and hitch arriving with the news that
the false charges against the survey
corps have been dropped and the capital
is now under the control of commander in
chief darius zackly due to a coup d'etat
levi's squad celebrates the news they
still have to rescue aaron and historia
though and hanji has an idea regarding
where they are hanji suspects that aaron
is going to be eaten in order to obtain
his titan power irwin had a report
commissioned on the reese estate and
assuming that aaron and historia were
captured by the reece family that's
likely where they're being held the day
while maria fell a group of bandits
burned down the village chapel while the
reese family was inside but fire alone
should not have destroyed a stone
building after escaping as the lone
survivor rodris rebuilt the place with
his own assets hanji finds it suspicious
so they head over there on the way levi
warns his squad that kenny ackerman will
be their biggest obstacle because
fighting him will be like fighting levi
himself he asks mikasa if she thinks
kenny might be related to her since they
share the same last name she thinks
about it and tells him that she knows
that her father's family was persecuted
but not the reason why levi then asks
her whether she experienced a moment
when she felt the sudden power awakened
inside her and she remembers the moment
she took up the knife to kill her
kidnapper levi tells her that he and
kenny also experience such moments in
their lives they arrive at the chapel
and find the secret door leading
underground the team makes preparations
for facing the anti-personnel control
squad which is waiting for them below
when they're ready they send barrels of
gunpowder and bags of oil down the
stairs sasha sets fire to them with a
flaming arrow and fills the underground
chamber with smoke reducing visibility
and the usefulness of firearms most of
the squad provides additional cover with
signal flares while mikasa and levi
scout out their enemies using vertical
maneuvering gear levi calls for his
squad to take out the interior and piece
and the team springs into action after a
concerted push they managed to force the
anti-personnel squad into a retreat
mikasa and the rest of levi's squad are
suddenly stopped by a bright flash
deeper in the cavern the squad arrives
in time for mikasa to catch historia who
had been flung back against the wall
from the force of rodrice's
transformation into a titan mikasa asks
if she is okay before taking the keys to
aaron's chains from her and throwing
them to levi so he can free him the
ceiling begins caving in trapping the
squad aaron apologizes for being useless
but levi and historia goad him into
taking matters into his own hands he
gets up and grabs a bottle labeled armor
that have fallen out of rod's bag and
breaks it between his teeth as he
transforms into a titan aaron's titan
form then crystallizes stabilizing the
cavern around the squad preventing them
from being crushed even after mikasa
helps cut him out of it his hardened
form does not disappear which levi
states is a huge development as they can
now seal the hole in walmaria mikasa
joins the rest of her squad in meeting
up with irwin and pulling back to orvo
district where they make preparations to
fight gargantuan titan that used to be
rod wiess at dawn the titan arrives and
aaron mikasa and armin assemble a stack
of barrels filled with gunpowder at
hanji's direction mikasa finds aaron
moping and prods him back to work
however to her surprise he punches his
own face to bring himself back to his
senses when rod reaches the wall levi
instructs the garrison soldiers to flee
while the survey corps soldiers dowse
themselves in water to withstand the
heat aaron changes into his titan form
and uses the stacked barrels as an
explosive by shoving them down rod's
open mouth mikasa joins the rest of the
survey court in cutting down the pieces
of titan that rained down to ensure that
the main body of rod reese is slain
after historia's coronation mikasa is
seen with her friends looking for levi
in order for historia to live up to the
last words that demo reeves spoke to her
when they find him historia punches them
in the r and olive squad levi shouts and
cheers however levi smiles at his squad
and thanks them in response much to
everyone's surprise two months later
historia can be seen running an
orphanage and taking care of abandoned
children aaron jean and armin talk about
historia's new role while sasha kanye
and mikasa help carry supplies when
historia finds them she tells them to
stop slacking while armin and jean go on
ahead she has a small conversation with
aaron but they're interrupted by a
stone-faced mikasa who takes the items
aaron was carrying saying he's tired
from all his training while the soldiers
eat and celebrate the success of the
executioner from hell fashioned by hanji
mikasa remained silent throughout most
of the conversation until aaron begins
to remember the day he ate his father
recognizing where his mind is going
mikasa stops him saying that he should
finish eating before talking he doesn't
stop trying to remember though and
suddenly he realizes that the man that
his father met that day while maria fell
was their old instructor keith shadis
the following day aaron mikasa armand
and others traveled to the training camp
to talk with keith shadis they talk
inside a small house and keith tells him
everything he knows how he met grisha
jaeger 20 years ago outside the walls
his relation with him and aaron's mother
during those years and how he was
present in the night grisha injected
aaron with the titan serum but did not
see anything and at the end does not
know anything about grisha's secrets
some days later thanks to aaron's
training and new technology developed by
hanji the operation to take back
walmaria is ready to begin the next day
that night the soldiers have a great
dinner to celebrate mika says present
eating and watching sasha's rampage and
jean and aaron's fight even when jean
blames aaron for the dangers that he
puts in mikasa she calmly decides not to
intervene when the fight ends she sits
with aaron and armin talking about their
future what will happen once they
reconquest walmaria and wondering if
everything will be like before however
armin not only thinks in that he
considers being part of their survey
corps will allow them to see the ocean
and the whole world the following day
the survey corps are ready to go to
shiganshina district after hearing the
cheers of the citizens irwin starts the
operation at sundown and mikasa rides
along squad levi towards shiganshina as
dawn approaches the corps walk within a
mountaintop forest mikasa leads aaron's
horse despite his complaints as the
others encourage him to rest as much as
possible for his upcoming duties jean
spots a nearby titan and hanji quickly
orders the group to illuminate the area
with their fragments of the reece chapel
cave hanji claims that it is dozing away
and the group moves on a few moments
after this mikasa begins to recognize
the area that they're in and claims that
she collected firewood there once before
aaron and armin also begin to recognize
the area and mikasa notes that she can
hear the river stream the group then
finds themselves near the shiganshina
district and races in on horses irwin
orders that all soldiers switch to
vertical maneuvering equipment and rush
the main gate covered by their hoods to
distract any watching enemies mikasa is
among the soldiers surrounding the gate
as aaron flies up above to transform
after aaron successfully seals the hole
in walmaria mikasa retrieves him from
his titan form and returns him to the
top of the wall giving aaron her cloak
mikasa accompanies the rest of her squad
as they return to meet up with erwin and
the rest of the survey corps however
before they can return they see a signal
flare fired by irwin and stop to wait
for their orders from her position
mikasa and her comrades are able to
observe as reiner reveals himself to be
hiding inside the wall and the beast
titan and his army materialized to
engage the survey corps after taking up
positions around the brawling aaron and
reiner mikasa waits until aaron is able
to maneuver reiner into an area of town
with tall buildings once aaron has
succeeded in this task mikasa and hanji
use their new thunderspears to blind him
the entire squad moves in and destroys
reiner's nape with their thunder spears
afterward mikasa attempts to console a
horrified armin but is interrupted by
reiner's titan form which begins roaring
after armin reveals to hanji that
berthold is approaching mikasa and the
rest of the soldiers retreat from
reiner's immediate vicinity in order to
escape being caught in the blast of
bertolt's transformation to titan form
when bertolt chooses not to transform in
order to check on reiner armin attempts
to negotiate with him however while
armin is attempting to talk with
berthold mikasa takes the opportunity to
attack bertolt from behind she is
unsuccessful in killing him and comments
on his drastic change in personality as
he flees when mikasa and armin are
returning to their comrades position
bertolt finally transforms and they're
forced to hide behind a building to
shield themselves from the blast they
then regroup with the rest of squad levi
and inform them that hanji's squad has
apparently been destroyed by the blast
mikasa suggests that armin take the lead
of their squad though armin then gives
jon command aaron tries to get bertol's
attention but he ignores them deciding
that they will have to engage bertolt
directly mikasa takes connie's
thunderspear and prepares to engage
bertolt while aaron attacks berto
directly mikasa and the rest of the
squad spread out to try and find an
opening to attack bertolt however before
they can act bertold kicks aaron into
the side of walmaria to mikasa's horror
jean assures her that aaron is not dead
and that their main concern at the
moment is taking down berthold jean
formulates a plan for he connie and
sasha to draw bertolt's attention while
mikasa strikes his nape with the
thunderspears just as mikasa moves into
strikeberthold he uses his steam to
prevent her from reaching him she asks
armin if he believes that there's any
possible way for them to fight back but
he sees none they are startled by the
sound of a house exploding behind them
from it emerges reiner his head fully
regenerated while armin and aaron choose
to confront the colossus titan mikasa
agrees to join the others in an attack
against the armored titan as reiner
begins to run to aaron mikasa sends one
of her thunder spears into his knees
crippling him she notices the colossus
titan in the distance beginning to emit
much steam causing her to worry about
aaron and armin for a moment before she
returns her focus to the attack on
dreiner while the others proceed with a
plan that they devised to defeat reiner
sasha is injured and misses her
thunderspear attack on the hinge of the
armored titan's jaw mikasa realizes that
since she has the only thunder spear
left and reiner's jaw has not been
completely unhinged she could not
proceed with the plan to blow reiner's
body out of his nape by sending a
thunderspear into his mouth as she
considers the situation hanji returns to
the battle sending their own
thunderspear at reiner and destroying
his other jaw hinge with the plan now on
the verge of success mikasa jumps into
reiner's mouth ordering him to get out
as she sends her final thundersphere
into his mouth defeating the armored
titan while hanji interrogates an
injured rhino mikasa begins treating
jon's injuries although hanji wants to
execute reiner zhang convinces them to
keep him alive long enough to steal his
powers with the titan injection hanji
orders mikasa to go retrieve the serum
from levi and to send up a signal flare
if there's a change of plans so that
hanji will know to kill reiner when
mikasa arrives at levi's position she's
horrified to find a hysterical errand
trying to keep a badly injured armin
alive as levi agrees to use the titan
serum to save armin's life mikasa shoots
a flare to notify hanji that reiner must
be killed however levi's mind is swayed
by the arrival of another soldier who
reveals that irwin is also mortally
wounded horrified by levi's announcement
that he will save irwin and not armin
mikasa draws her blade and begins to
advance upon him as levi punches aaron
in the face mikasa pins him to the
rooftop and draws her blade to his neck
noticing how worn out levi is she
attempts to grab the titan serum from
his hand as levi reminds her that
without irwin's strength humanity can
never defeat the titans when flock
approaches her she flips her blade in
order to strike him with the blunt side
of the sword and knocks him down only to
be stopped by hanji zoy as they both
struggle mikasa eventually capitulates
remembering a happier time when she
aaron and armin were children as tears
rolled down her face after armin returns
to his human form mikasa along with
aaron picks him up off the ground as she
cries tears of joy to see he is alive
and well atop the wall after aaron
informs armin of what has happened after
the battle ended hanji orders mikasa
levi and aaron to continue surveying and
head for the jaeger family's house upon
reaching the basement's door aaron tries
to open the door's lock and is surprised
that the key does not fit mikasa says
that she is sure that that was the key
dr jaeger had levi then proceeds and
kicks down the door and they enter the
room they find it had been set up to
appear as much as possible a common
doctor's office however after further
investigation mikasa discovers a keyhole
on a locked drawer in the desk which the
key unlocks the drawer seemed empty at
first but levi notices the false bottom
and under it were three hidden books
kept intact with the various
preservatives mikasa and aaron open the
first book and within it they find an
uncannily realistic portrait of grisha
standing beside a fair-haired woman and
a child on the back of it grisha had
written that it is not an illustration
it is called a photograph and that
humanity has not perished upon returning
to the walls aaron and mikasa are put in
prison cells as punishment for their
actions against levi during this time
armin visits them and logs aaron's
memories as he retells them of many
events in his father grisha's life that
matched up with what was found in the
books in his basement among these
memories is a conversation between him
and aaron krueger an allied spy to the
eldean restorationists during this
conversation krueger tells grisha that
anyone who has inherited the power of
the titans will only live for 13 more
years as no one with this power can
outlive its original owner ymir fritz
who founded the nation of elder and all
its subjects upon hearing this
revelation mikasa becomes very depressed
and denies its validity knowing that
armin and aaron only have a short number
of years left to live if it's true after
hanji the current commander puts too
much pressure on aaron in the next
prison cell levi orders them free mikasa
leaves her cell having lost weight in
her state of depression mikasa attends a
military meeting on how to proceed with
the findings of the basement in trost
she sits silently as hanji deliberates
their interpretation of the events but
is shocked and confused when aaron
shouts all of a sudden during the
meeting mikasa then continues being
quiet until the conclusion of the
meeting with the decision made to
release all discoveries made by the
survey corps to the public the nine
surviving members of the survey corps
later attend a ceremony to be honored
for their success in the battle of
shiganshina district before the start of
the ceremony aaron gets into an argument
with flock over armand being saved over
commander irwin when she attempts to
calm aaron down flock commends mikasa
over her acting like an adult and giving
up and saving armin this statement
surprises and upsets her she would later
go on to be commemorated for her bravery
in shiganshina with a medal roughly a
year after the battle of trust district
the titan guillotines had eradicated all
titans within walmaria allowing citizens
to repopulate shiganshina the survey
corps was able to hold an expedition
beyond the walls for the first time in
six years after following a deformed
titans trail the survey corps reached
the edge of parody island and behold the
ocean the survey corps dismounts their
horses discard their boots and head to
the beachfront mikasa is started by an
ocean wave but goes on to give armin a
warm smile she listens as armin begins
to joyfully talk with aaron over the
size of the ocean however these happy
moments fade as aaron solemnly states
that the ocean does not hold freedom and
enemies are over the other side one year
after retaking shiganshina mikasa goes
with the other members of the survey
court to intercept a survey ship sent
from marley like the others present
mikasa is surprised to see two sailors
rebel and force the others to surrender
while watching the two meet with levi
and hanji mikasa ponders what their plan
might be while trying to wake up sasha
an alliance is formed between parody and
the group of rebels calling themselves
the anti-marlian volunteers and
preparations and training begin for the
impeding war with marley while at a
firing range mikasa and armin both agree
that it's good to see both sides are
getting along with each other but are
visibly troubled by aaron's insistence
that parody must launch a preemptive
assault on marley to buy themselves more
time to prepare
later on mikasa is among the survey
corps members that meet with an
ambassador from the nation of hizuru
named kiyomi azumabito at a meeting
between the two parties kiyomi displays
the crest of the azumabito clan and
mikasa is shaken to see it is the same
as a tattoo on her wrist
after some prompting by aaron mikasa
shares it saying that her mother gave it
to her as a girl and to pass it down to
her children later on
kiyomi describes how both hizuru and
eldia were allies long ago and laments
that the nation suffered after the great
titan war kyomi finishes by stating that
mikasa is the descendant of hizuru's
lost lord and the hope for their nation
although mikasa is overwhelmed by this
information historia is ecstatic
believing that hizuru will be more
willing to trust parody due to mikasa's
lineage later after spending the day
building train tracks aaron mentions
that he only has roughly five years left
to live and begins to consider who he
should pass his titan abilities to
mikasa immediately volunteers herself
bhajan advises against it mikasa is half
asian and they don't know what the
ackerman clan is as the others volunteer
themselves also aaron decides to not
choose any of them due to valuing their
friendship and not wanting to have any
of their lives forcibly cut short on his
behalf mikasa is one of several server
corpsmen who journeyed to marley's
mainland to meet with kiyomi when aaron
leaves in the middle of the meeting
mikasa and the rest of the 104th
graduates go searching for him mikasa
finds him looking at a cluster of
refugee tents at first she begins to
reprimand him for going outside alone
when he is their enemy's most wanted
target but then she realizes that he's
looking at the boy who stole from sasha
and levi earlier in the day as well as
the boy's family aaron tells her that
these tents are where these people live
after losing their homes to war the
people here are like the two of them one
day life stopped being normal and
everything was taken away he asks mikasa
why she cares about him so much whether
it's because he saved her when they were
kids or because their family mika says
stammers at first but then replies that
he is family the rest of their friends
arrive and interrupt their conversation
disappointing aaron the group end up
having dinner with the family living
near the azumabito estate spending the
night drinking and carousing the
soldiers sit in on a hearing between
politicians to discuss ld and
mistreatment they're horrified when the
speakers begin calling for the hatred
being shown towards eldians to be
redirected towards the audience living
on parody as they're listening mikasa
notices aaron quietly depart from the
meeting as aaron begins his assault on
the marlians mikasa joins the survey
corps in retrieving him and attacking
liberio during the battle between aaron
and the warhammer titan mikasa attacks
the warhammer from behind using a
modified mount with multiple
thunderspears she launches all eight at
the warhammer's nape seven of which
lands solidly in the neck where they
explode
mikasa lands on the shoulder of the
decapitated attack titan and asks aaron
to come home
she later questions him if he has any
idea of what he's done as he's killed
civilians including children and there's
no way to undo that however aaron
doesn't answer the question and instead
points out that the warhammer titan is
still alive
mikasa is shocked to see the titan
standing up since she's sure that she
destroyed its nape completely and the
warhammer titan then fires a pike of its
hardened substance towards them mikasa
quickly grabs aaron and flees away of
the attack titan's body barely avoiding
getting struck
aaron comes up with a plan to defeat and
eat the warhammer titan and asks mikasa
to distract the enemy enough for him to
enact it mikasa re-engages the warhammer
titan while aaron transforms back into
the attack titan and captures the
younger sister of willy who was hiding
under the ground encasing crystal and
controlling the warhammer remotely via a
long cord mikasa watches as aaron severs
the connection and prepares to eat the
younger sister of willy but then is
horrified to see galliard attacking him
from behind and she and levi go to aid
him after levi and aaron managed to hold
off galliard mikasa intercepts him and
knocks him down off the wall with a
thunderspear other survey corps soldiers
come to fight the titan but they're shot
by the panzer unit on top peak's car
titan although mikasa is among the ones
who managed to escape
she then sees aaron being caught off
guard by the reappearance of the
warhammer titan and zeke jaeger's beast
titan arriving to the battle as zeke
joins galliard and peak and orders them
not to let anyone escape and wipe them
all out levi orders the core to face
their enemies and to survive while the
survey court and warriors clash mikasa
attempts to destroy the warhammer's
crystal with a thunderspear but it fails
to even crack staying close to aaron she
watches as he then unsuccessfully tries
to consume the crystal she witnesses an
explosion at the nearby harbor signaling
the arrival of armin and the colossus
titan when the jaw titan attempts to
charge aaron mikasa intervenes having
worn an updated set of the traditional
vertical maneuvering gear alongside the
anti-personnel variant she draws her
blades and prepares to fight it once
more
mikasa swings her swords at the jaw
titan but it lunges out of the way and
goes for the attack titan she follows it
and tries to provide support and as it
momentarily breaks off from the attack
mikasa notes that this current jaw titan
is much faster and different from
yamir's titan
it then switches its focus from aaron to
an incoming airship that serves as the
survey core's method of retreat from the
battle
mikasa anticipated the jaw titan going
after it and manages to catch it off
guard she comes from underneath it and
throws it off balance by slicing through
both legs and severs one of its feet
mikasa observes aaron using the jaw
titan to kill and consume the powers of
the warhammer titan
after aaron gets caught by surprise from
reiner's armor titan mikasa flies to
aaron and convinces him to come back
home she then leaves with aaron and
flies toward the incoming airship
after they board the airship levi kicks
aaron due to his insubordination
infuriating mikasa she tries to protest
but is stopped by armin the four meet
with zeke and yelana at another part of
the ship a commotion ensues outside and
connie and jean enter the room carrying
two captured stowaways jean announces
that one of them shot sasha and she's
unlikely to survive prompting mikasa and
armin to run out of the room to see her
sasha dies from her injuries with mikasa
and armin feudally trying to wake her as
mikasa is visiting sasha's grave she's
interrupted by the sound of connie and
jean saving niccolo from being harassed
by a military police brigade soldier as
nicolo pays his respects to sasha mikasa
informs him of how she died later that
night mikasa is with armin kanye jean
with the latter expressing dismay that
the anti-marlin volunteers were arrested
when connie mentions that they should be
prepared to kill aaron if he sides with
their enemy mikasa opposes him but he
glares at her and asks if she would side
with the enemy too
mikasa says no but claims that aaron
still cares for them and tries to
convince them his recent behavior is
reflective of that
the others don't believe her and jean
brings up the fact that despite this
aaron still had no problem forcing them
to fight and that resulted in sasha's
death
mikasa is further shocked when connie
stated that aaron laughed when told that
sasha had died armin decides they should
prepare for a worst-case scenario to
have someone turn and kill aaron if he
proves to be a threat make us a protest
that he still has several years left but
armin states they'll decide what happens
after confirming where aaron stands
after a group of survey corps recruits
leaked the news of aaron's arrest to the
public and are found out mikasa attends
the hearing that hanji conducts with
them after hearing them out hunty orders
the perpetrators jailed for their
actions and mikasa escorts one of them
louise to her cell
luiz tries to justify aaron's actions
and convince mikasa to help free him but
mikasa simply cuts her off and leaves
she meets up with armin and notifies him
that darius zackly has agreed to see
them both of them are stunned to hear
zachary refuse their request to see
aaron and mikasa is taken aback by the
possibility that zeke yeager has been
controlling aaron's behavior and
movements prior to the attack on liberio
after being sent away mikasa notices
several military police soldiers enter
zackly's office and decides to eavesdrop
armin tries to persuade her not to but
she insists on knowing what direction
the survey core is going suddenly she
grabs armin and dives away just as an
explosion goes off in zackly's office
they both go outside and see zachary's
dismembered corpse from the blast mikasa
is speechless about who could have been
behind the assassination as the crowd of
protesters chant in approval
during an emergency meeting by the other
heads of the military mikasa hears
armand testify that he observed recruits
from the survey corps leave the area and
were most likely responsible for the
explosion she's shocked to hear that
aaron has escaped confinement and
blocked his escape route so no one could
follow him mikasa accompanies armin
hanji and onyakupan as the military
conduct a search for the renegades
staring blankly ahead and unresponsive
to armit as he tries to calm her later
mikasa attends another meeting to plan
the military's response to the emergence
of the rebels now dubbed the jaegerists
as the meeting concludes kiyomi pulls
mikasa aside to ask her to consider
fleeing to the azumabito's ship if the
need arises mikasa thanks her for her
consideration though makes it clear that
she sees herself as an ld and foremost
and intends to see the fate of the
island that raised her heading outside
with the other survey court veterans
mikasa briefly squabbles with connie
over aaron's connection to the yagarists
and over being suspected
believing zeke to have a secret scheme
the core right out to a lead a
restaurant employing marlian workers
after arriving for their investigation
and meeting up with nicolo mikasa and
the others wait in a back room for him
to finish his work a short while later
armin calls everybody into the main room
where nicolo is attacking the runaway
warrior candidates over the murder of
sasha eventually when mr blaus's
understanding attitude calms the
situation down mikasa goes over to the
female candidate to check on her wounds
suddenly another young girl named kaya
attempts to stab the candidate however
mikasa blocks the attack mikasa and
armin take her into the next room as the
blaus family weep in a separate room
mikasa sits with gabby and armin when
asked by gabby why she saved her mikasa
does not give any reason why when aaron
unexpectedly appears before they can say
anything aaron silently holds up his
right hand which is bleeding
understanding aaron's intent if they
don't comply mikasa and armin obey his
request to sit down at the table as they
hear flock lead the others away mikasa
can only sit in stunned silence while
aaron and armin begin to talk when aaron
mentions himself finally being free
mikasa says that he is not and is being
controlled by zeke she mentions how
aaron was not like this ever before and
brings up how he saved her from being
kidnapped all those years ago pointing
to the scarf aaron gave her aaron glares
at her and firmly reminds her to keep
her hands on the table stunned by this
reaction mikasa silently complies
after aaron calls armin a useless
traitor mikasa asks aaron what he's
doing and hears that aaron learned about
her family's lineage from zeke as well
she hears from aaron that the ackerman
clan can manifest the power of the
titans while remaining in human form he
muses that her instincts as an ackerman
are the sole reason why mikasa has stuck
by him for so long bringing up the
example of her attempted kidnapping
aaron reminds mikasa that she only acted
when he told her to realizing this
mikasa tries to explain it off but aaron
remarks that ackerman's also suffer
severe headaches due to their true
selves fighting the urge to protect the
host recalling that it happened to her
aaron flatley states the real mikasa
died that day in a hut and all that is
left are her acumen instincts mikasa is
unable to speak and starts to break down
and cry when aaron claims he has always
hated her calling her nothing more than
an obedient slave when armin tries to
assault aaron mikasa swiftly blocks his
attack and slams him into the table much
to both their shock and horror as aaron
starts beating armin mikasa continues to
cry and begs him to stop aaron then
orders her armin and gabby taken away to
shigansena district afterwards mikasa is
relocated to a prison cell alongside the
other captives during her imprisonment
jean inquires more about her recent
encounter with aaron from armin but
mikasa rebuffs the remarks not wanting
to explain they're then interrupted by
yelena who came to explain zeke's true
intentions afterwards mikasa remains
idle as the others react to yelena's
explanation of the euthanization plan as
the fight on the rooftop ensues mikasa
and the other prisoners wonder what the
sound overhead them was about onyankabon
arrived shortly to release them
requesting that all imprisoned soldiers
joined the fight against marley to keep
aaron safe as they had to put on sets of
vertical maneuvering equipment mikasa
and armin discuss what aaron's
motivations might be for pushing them
away although armit is unsure of aaron's
intentions he assures mikasa that aaron
was lying about her ackermann genes and
simply used his knowledge of her
headaches to give his lie credence as
she's suiting up mikasa is visited by
louise who tries to bond with her mikasa
ignores the girl and departs for the
battlefield before leaving she folds up
the scarf given to her by aaron and
leaves it behind along with the others
mikasa notices zeke getting shot and
falling off the wall as armin decides
they must neutralize the kart titan both
of them are shot at by several marlian
soldiers hiding in a nearby house after
connie destroys it with a thunderspear
mikasa goes with arm into the car titan
while commander pixis and nile doc of
the military police coordinate efforts
on the ground suddenly a loud scream is
heard throughout the district mikasa
sees several flashes of light and
realizes that zeke has transformed the
affected soldiers into pure titans
reaching the top of the wall where the
car titan is stationed mikasa saves
armin after he destroys the titan
artillery cannon atop its back she is
then charged by the car titan and angles
out of range while preparing to strike
it before they can engage aaron and zeke
make contact causing the wall to
collapse and abruptly ending mikasa's
attack mikasa and armin are horrified to
see the titans inside emerging looking
at eren's new titan form mikasa wonders
if there was any other choice they could
have made or if she had answered
differently when aaron had asked her
what he meant to her that could have
avoided the battle that they find
themselves in now as the wall titans
begin to march armin assumes that aaron
is using the founding titan to send the
wall titans to attack the forces
amassing in marley to attack parody
however he's perplexed to see that all
of walmaria is crumbling telling mika
said that an attack on marley should
have only required the titans contained
in shinganchina's outer wall they're
interrupted by aaron who begins speaking
to all subjects of the emir through the
founding titan tamika's shock aaron
declares that he's going to be using the
founding titan to completely exterminate
all life outside of parody island
mikasai and armin regroup with jean and
connie who have falco with them noticing
their fellow soldiers being attacked by
titans armin and jean go to help them
but mikasa points out that they need to
deal with falco jean suggests feeding
the boy to one of the titans while
connie argues that his mother should be
allowed to eat falco armin does not want
to sacrifice falco at all arguing that
killing him will only breed more
animosity with the warriors the group is
attacked by titan allowing connie to
flee with falco before the group can
stop him the group returns to the
military headquarters where they rally
the soldiers trapped inside to help them
kill the titans which have amassed
around the building after clearing out
the first wave of titans mikasa's group
lies in wait at the building while more
soldiers lead the remaining titans to
the building to be killed when combat
had ended mr blouse brings mikasa and
armin to go meet with gabby who begs
them to return falco to her armin
explains what has happened to falco and
gabby desperately tries to argue that
aaron can return connie's mother to
normal with the founding titan in order
to spare falco gabby argues that he was
capable of even removing the armored
titan's hardened skin prompting mikasa
to ask gabby about reiner's whereabouts
mikasa tries to convince armin not to
pursue kanye to ragako but is
unsuccessful as armin is leaving mikasa
tries to ask armin what they will do
about aaron causing armin to lash out at
her for not focusing on more pressing
issues that they have he then tells her
that erwin would have had better
judgment in that moment and departs as
armin leaves mikasa notices that her
scarf is no longer where she left it
mikasa later finds jean and flock with a
dead volunteer and demands to know what
happened flock claims to be acting on
aaron's behalf to wipe out any
resentment parody might have flock
attempts to recruit jean but mikasa
interrupts him demanding to know what
happened to hanji and levi flock claims
to her shock that zeke killed them the
next morning mikasa finds louise in the
infirmary wearing her missing scarf
louise claims that erin told her to
throw the scarf away so she decided to
take it instead prompting mikasa to
demand that she return it immediately
later mikasa and jean are contacted by
hanji who informs the two of the plan to
join forces with marley to stop aaron
mikasa agrees to it after receiving the
signal from jean to leave the military
headquarters mikasa departs with her
comrades on their way out of shiganshina
they pick up and join forces with annie
and reiner that night the combined
forces of marley and parody share a meal
as they discuss how to oppose aaron as
tensions run high between the survey
corps and the warriors annie demands to
know if the corps will be able to kill
aaron if no other option is presented
mika says states that killing aaron is
not the only way to stop him confirming
any suspicions that mikasa and her
friends would try to stop the warriors
from killing aaron mikasa steps up to
confront annie but she defuses the
situation by assuring mikasa that she
has no issue with aaron living if he can
be convinced to stop the rumbling the
next day the group travels to paradise
harbor with the intention of using the
azumabito clan's airship to pursue aaron
only to find that the harbor has been
occupied by jaegerists as the group
gears up for a confrontation annie
suggests launching an all-out attack and
mikasa reminds her that they cannot risk
getting the azumabito killed in the
crossfire the discussion is interrupted
by hanji who reveals to everyone's heart
that aaron and his titans have
apparently already reached marley the
group settles on a plan to try to trick
flock into handing over the azumabito
mechanics so that they can operate the
ship flock instead tries to execute the
azumabito necessitating mikasa to
intervene and save them mikasa helps
kiomi disarm flock and his guards but
flock manages to escape and alert the
other jaegerists to their attack mikasa
hanji jean and magath lead kiomi and the
mechanics to the basement of the
building that they were being kept in
and take shelter there so that annie and
reiner can transform and fight without
risk of collateral damage after it is
decided that the flying boat will be
taken to odiha so that it can be
prepared for flight under more favorable
conditions mikasa brings news of the
change to annie and reiner and instructs
them to protect the azumabito service
crew as mikasa engages the jaegerists
she is alerted by hanji about
reinforcements arriving by train but is
shocked to see the train derail itself
once the boat is ready to depart mikasa
helps carry an injured annie on board on
board the ship mikasa and jean are seen
holding back annie who is in distress
after hanji reveals that liberio cannot
be saved from the rumbling anymore upon
arriving in oriha mikasa helps out with
the preparations for the flying boat to
take off while working mikasa suggests
that annie practiced with the new
anti-personnel equipment but annie
reiterates that she does not intend to
continue helping the group mikasa
notices annie watching armin and reminds
her that he will be going with them to
find aaron but annie does not change her
mind annie asks mikasa if she will kill
aaron to save humanity and mikasa claims
that she will not as work on a flying
boat nears completion mikasa and the
other soldiers prepare to depart however
flock reveals himself inside the hangar
having followed them across the ocean
and fires on them mikasa fires one of
her anchors into flock's throat killing
him before he can harm anyone but she is
not quick enough to stop him from
rupturing the boat's fuel tank as
aaron's titans arrive in oriha the group
is forced to depart without hanji who
stays behind to buy them time to escape
and route to aaron mikasa participates
in the meeting to discuss the best plan
to stop him during the meeting mikasa
inquires about reiner's hunch that aaron
wants to be stopped by someone the
meeting is interrupted as the group is
being pulled into paths by aaron as his
comrades try to talk aaron down mikasa
pleads for aaron to return to them
seeing aaron in the distance mikasa and
the others try to reach him but are
unable to get any closer aaron tells him
that he called them to paths to let them
know that they will have to kill him to
stop the rumbling before sending them
back to the flying boat as the flying
boat reaches aaron it comes under fire
from the beast titan mikasa and her
comrades jump from the boat and use
their maneuvering gear to evade the
beast's projectiles before engaging it
directly the group makes short work of
the beast titan only to find that zeke
is not inside its nape mikasa is alarmed
when armin decides to transform and use
the explosion to find zeke but armin
reassures her that he does not intend to
kill aaron however before armin can
execute his plan an army of titans
begins generating atop aaron and abducts
him pique is disabled while trying to
blow up aaron's nape and levi orders his
squad to focus on saving armin they do
not get far before bertolt hoover's
colossus titan appears it disables
reiner's titan and throws it at the
group knocking them off aaron's titan
mikasa is left as the only soldier with
functioning maneuvering equipment in any
state to fight leaving her as the only
one to defend her comrades from the
approaching titans mustering her
strength mikasa prepares to make a last
stand against the titans only for them
all to be whisked to safety by falco who
has learned to fly in his titan form
atop falco's titan mikisa reveals to
annie that armin has been captured by
aaron's titans and asks annie to help
rescue him levi decides to have the
group split up to simultaneously rescue
armin and detonate the explosives on
aaron's nape to mikasa's horror mikisa
tries to change her friends minds but is
unsuccessful and annie orders her to
focus on rescuing armin to take her mind
off of aaron arriving in aaron's titan's
tailbone mikasa connie and annie
identify the titan which took armin and
begin their pursuit of it as the three
fight off the titans which attacked them
the okapi titan which took armin flees
and mikasa has annie throw her in its
direction in the hopes of catching up to
it however other titans begin physically
shielding it and she eventually breaks
her blades on the skin of an armored
titan and he saves mikasa from the armor
but the two of them and connie are left
surrounded as the okapi flees to
bertolt's colossus titan just as they
are about to be overwhelmed berthold's
titan intervenes and begins fighting
alongside them mikasa uses the
opportunity to pursue the okapi again
and is finally able to cut armin out of
its mouth after gabby shoots it in the
head jean manages to detonate aaron's
nape thanks to the help of their new
allies and mikasa joins her friends in
evacuating atop falco's titan so that
armin can transform as the group touches
down and force salta mikasa begins
suffering from another headache grieving
that the last conversation she had with
aaron ended with him claiming he hated
her the group is relieved to see that
reiner survived armin's transformation
but they're disheartened to see that
aaron and the centipede also survived
tamika says distress levi decides that
the only hope they have of stopping the
rumbling is killing aaron so that the
source cannot reattach itself to him the
source begins emitting smoke into salta
and the soldiers realize that it's
attempting to transform the albians in
the fort into pure titans leaving behind
jean and connie mikasa joins levi and
peak in boarding falco and departing to
face aaron once again as they draw near
to aaron mikasa experiences another
strong headache and is suddenly brought
into a path's place by aaron mikasa is
living in isolation with aaron following
the decision to run away from the parade
marlin conflict aaron notices that
mikasa has been crying and mikasa
wonders if it's okay for her to be there
aaron muses that the only option they
had was to run away and live out the
rest of his four years in peace together
mikasa apologizes for bringing up the
past and aaron asks her to forget about
him when he dies in the real world
mikasa says that she cannot forget him
tying her scarf around her neck once
again mikasa tells levi that aaron is
inside his titan's mouth
and asks him to help her reach him levi
uses a thundersphere to blow a hole in
aaron's titan mouth and mikasa enters it
immediately severing aaron's head from
the spine kissing aaron mika subbids him
goodbye carrying aaron's head mikasa
finds armin on the battlefield and the
two mourn their friend's death mikasa
tells armin that she plans to leave on
her own so that she can give aaron a
proper burial the two agree that the
best place to bury him is at the foot of
the tree that he liked to nap under and
mikasa departs mikasa returns to parody
island and true to her word makes a
small grave for aaron at the tree that
he liked to sleep under outside of
shiganshina district three years after
his death mikasa visits aaron's grave
and reveals that their friends are going
to be coming to visit him soon wishing
to see him again mikasa begins to cry
her tears are interrupted by a bird
which grabs the end of her scarf and
tightens it before flying away as she
watches the bird fly away mikasa thanks
aaron for wrapping the scarf around her
once more
thank you guys so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us we'll
see you guys very soon in one of our
next videos